في هذا الفندق الواقع في وسط لندن الذي يستضيف
اللاجئين الأفغان تتراكم تبرعات اللاجئين الأفغان
لدينا مثل منتجات الزينة
مثل الشامبو وأطعمة الأطفال هناك يعمل المتطوعون
هنا يوميًا لدعم
اللاجئين الذين تم إجلاؤهم من قبل الحكومة البريطانية
، وقد أتى الكثير منهم
بحقيبة ظهر فقط حتى لو كان ذلك  من
بينهم لم يرتدوا أحذية على أقدامهم ، لقد
كانوا يرتدون نفس الملابس لمدة أسبوع
، كانت عزيزة وطفلاها الصغار من
بين الآلاف الذين تم نقلهم جواً من كابول
، أخبرتني أن الفرار من طالبان
كان تجربة مؤلمة ولكن
دعمهم ولطفهم
لقد منحها المتطوعون الأمل في حياة أفضل
في المملكة المتحدة ،
وآمل أن أعيش بدون خوف وأن أعيش في
سلام وأمان مع أطفالي
وعائلتي.
الأسرة تغادر أفغانستان
بعد دخول طالبان كان الجميع
خائفين كان الجميع مذعورين للغاية وخائفين
كانت كابول في وضع سيء للغاية
كان الناس في حالة رعب.  كان الناس
يخشون مغادرة
منازلهم ، وتخطط الحكومة لإعادة توطين حوالي
20000 لاجئ أفغاني بما في ذلك 5000 خلال
العام المقبل ، والتي
يطلق عليها اسم العملية ، نرحب ترحيباً حاراً بأن
خطة إعادة التوطين ستعطي الأولوية
لأولئك الذين ساعدوا جهود المملكة المتحدة في
أفغانستان للسماح للاجئين القادمين
إلى البلاد من خلال الطرق الرسمية
للحصول على إقامة دائمة
ولكن بالنسبة لأكثر من 3000 مواطن أفغاني موجودون
بالفعل في نظام اللجوء ،
كان الاستقبال بعيدًا عن الدفء
بموجب سياسة الحكومة الحالية.
بدلاً من ذلك ،
يواجهون الانتظار المؤلم لمعرفة ما إذا كان
سيتم رفضهم
في أكسفورد أليسون أم لا ، ويعمل الفريق في
استضافة الملاذ على
مدار الساعة لربط طالبي اللجوء الأفغان
بالعائلات المضيفة المؤقتة ، ومن
الصعب ترك الناس في طي النسيان من
قبل الحكومة.  يقول أنه ليس من الآمن
إعادتهم الآن هل يعتقدون حقًا
أنها ستكون آمنة
لإرسالهم مرة أخرى في المرة التالية ، لا أعرف ما بين خمس
إلى عشر سنوات نتعرض للقصف
برسائل البريد الإلكتروني من أشخاص من جميع أنحاء
البلاد يقولون فيها ما يمكننا فعله للمساعدة في
ما يمكننا فعله للمساعدة
ويقترح العديد منهم ذلك  نعم
بالطبع لديهم سرير احتياطي ،
غرفة احتياطية يمكنهم توفيرها
لكيت لاجئ ، ومن
بين عشرات العائلات في جميع أنحاء المملكة المتحدة التي
تستعد لاستضافة طالبي اللجوء الأفغان
الذين يعتقدون أن على الدولة واجب
دعم شعبها.
نظرًا لحقيقة أننا مسؤولون جزئيًا
عن الموقف الذي يجدون أنفسهم
فيه ، نشعر أنه من الصواب فعل شيء
حيال هذا ، فنحن محظوظون جدًا لأننا نمتلك
منزلًا جميلًا ، كلانا لديه وظائف تعرف
أن لدينا عائلتنا هم  لم تحصل على أي شيء ،
فلماذا لا
تشارك بعضًا من ذلك
مع شخص آخر تعرفه
شخصًا يحتاج إليه
أكثر منا
في الوقت الحالي ، تقول الحكومة إنها
أوقفت مؤقتًا جميع عمليات الإعادة القسرية للمواطنين الأفغان
الذين تم رفض منحهم حق اللجوء مع أولئك الموجودين في
أكد خطر الاضطهاد أنهم
لن يتوقعوا عودتهم إلى أفغانستان ،
لكن حتى اتخاذ قرار ، يظل
مستقبل الآلاف من الأفغان المستضعفين هنا
في المملكة المتحدة غير مؤكد في أحسن الأحوال
ندير بشير CNN لندن